en el último vídeo empezamos a hablar
acerca de dados digamos que estamos
jugando un monopolio turista mundial o
uno de sus juegos en donde tienes que
tirar dos dados y entonces tenemos dos
dados y hicimos aquí una cuadrícula y
pusimos aquí todos los posibles
resultados de tirar el dado uno que pues
como tiene seis caras nos puede salir
uno dos tres cuatro cinco o seis y de
este lado pusimos todo lo que nos puede
salir en el dado dos así es que tenemos
en esta cuadrícula todos los posibles
resultados de tirar los dos dados aunque
hay por ejemplo está castilla representa
el resultado en el que en el dado uno
tiramos un 6 y en el dado 2 tiramos un 6
también esta otra casilla representa el
resultado en el que en el primer dado
sacamos 4 y en el segundo dado tiramos 1
ahora si estamos jugando turista mundial
lo que nos interesa es cuánto suman los
dos dados entonces por ejemplo en este
en el que tenemos seis en los dos lados
podemos escribir en esta casilla 12 que
es la suma de los dos lados entonces de
hecho podemos hacer eso para cada una de
las casillas si sacamos 1 y 1 la suma es
un 2 por aquí 1 y 2 es 34
567 luego 2 y 1 es 3 4 5 6 7 8
3 y 1 es 4 5
7 8 y 9 se ven ahí unos patrones muy
interesantes o sea por ejemplo aquí
podría continuar 5
7 pero bueno vamos por orden aquí
7 8 9 10
7 8 9 10 11
8 9 10 11 y 12 ahora si lo que nos
interesa es la probabilidad de obtener
un 7 a la hora de sumar los dos dados
pues lo que tenemos que hacer es
fijarnos en todos estos posibles
resultados que además son x probables
como vamos a ver pronto y utilizar la
definición más primitiva de probabilidad
que es casos favorables casos
ahora
entre casos totales casos
totales totales donde pues los casos
favorables son los casos que en este
caso son las casillas en las que se
cumple la condición de la que estamos
tratando de sacar la probabilidad que en
este caso es que los dados sumen 7
entonces aquí tenemos la suma de los dos
dados y nos fijamos en cuáles de estas
casillas la suma de los dos dados es
igual a 7 a ver aquí hay una está está
esta esta y ésta entonces hay 123 456
casos favorables
a ver esto lo vamos a continuar por acá
seis casos favorables y en total hay a
ver cuántas casillas hay pues hay seis
por seis no y 6 por 66
entonces la probabilidad de que la suma
de los dos lados sea igual a 7 es 6
entre 36 que es igual a un sexto
ahora podemos usar esta definición de
que la probabilidad sea igual a los
casos favorables entre los casos totales
porque cada una de estas casillas es x
probable ahora porque son equipo
probable todas estas casillas pues
porque cada uno de estos dados que hay
con la misma probabilidad en cualquiera
de estos seis números lo que hay de
hecho que hay en cada uno de estos
números con probabilidad un sexto que
podemos poner aquí las probabilidades
el chiste es que además los dos dados
son independientes entonces la
probabilidad digamos por ejemplo caer en
esta castilla es igual a la probabilidad
de que el dado 2 haya caído en el 3 y el
dado 1 haya caído en el 5 entonces como
son independientes la probabilidad de
caer aquí es un sexto
sexto por y la probabilidad de que el
dado 1 que ayer aquí también es un sexto
un sexto que es igual a un 36 sabor
y lo mismo exactamente lo mismo pasa
para cualquiera de las otras casillas y
esta otra casilla tiene probabilidad un
sexto por un sexto que es un 36 a vo y
lo mismo para todas las casillas
entonces los posibles resultados que son
cada una de estas casillas
sonic y probables y por lo tanto podemos
usar esta fórmula de probabilidad de
casos favorables entre casos totales y
bueno así como calculamos la
probabilidad de que la suma de los dos
dados sea igual a 7 usando esta
cuadrícula esta misma cuadrícula nos
sirve para calcular la probabilidad de
que los dados sumen cualquier cosa
aunque lo único que tenemos que hacer es
contar cuánto son los casos favorables y
también nos sirve para tener una mejor
intuición acerca de los dados por
ejemplo aquí se puede ver claramente que
la probabilidad de sacar 8 es
exactamente igual a la probabilidad de
sacar 6 también se ve muy claramente que
lo más probable es que saquemos un 7
porque es el 1 con número que tiene una
diagonal completa todos los demás
abarcan diagonales que tienen menos
casillas ahora sacamos la probabilidad
de sacar un 8 de que la suma de los dos
dados sea 8 aunque la probabilidad de
sacar 8 y contamos los casos favorables
1 2 3 4 5
entonces ponemos casos favorables que
son 5 entre casos totales que es el
número de casillas que es 36 y así
podemos demostrar que la probabilidad de
sacar 8 es igual a la probabilidad de
sacar 6 porque tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
casillas en las que sacamos 6 entonces
la probabilidad de sacar 6 es igual a 5
que son los casos favorables entre 36
entonces estas probabilidades en efecto
son iguales y la probabilidad de sacar 5
1 2 3 4 es igual a 4 36 a vos que es
igual a un noveno aunque entonces la
probabilidad de sacar 9 la probabilidad
de sacar 9 también es igual a un noveno
y de hecho todo este tipo de cosas te
pueden servir bastante cuando estés
jugando turista mundial o escalera o ese
otro tipo de juegos de mesa y bueno ese
tiro de 7 es muy importante porque es el
más probable de todos de hecho es más
probable sacar 7 a sacar 4 o 11 a ver
vamos a escribirlo por aquí la
probabilidad de sacar un 4 o sacar un 11
es menor que la probabilidad de sacar un
7 no sé aquí tenemos dos opciones para
sacar y aquí nada más une pero pues es
que es el 7 a ver la probabilidad de
sacar 4 o sacar 11 es igual a la
probabilidad de sacar 4 más la
probabilidad de sacar 11 la probabilidad
de sacar 4
es 336 a los
336 a vos
la probabilidad de sacar 11 que es 12
236 a vos aunque entonces en total la
probabilidad de sacar 4 o
11 es igual a 3 + 2
536 a vos sin embargo la probabilidad de
sacar 7 636 ambos
636 a vos
entonces si sacar alguno de estos
cuatros o sacar alguno de estos 11 es es
menos probable que sacan un 7 pero bueno
tal vez no debería de colorear los así
porque 11 y 4 no tienen la misma
probabilidad
pero bueno aunque probablemente esto de
la cuadrícula sea la forma más fácil de
calcular estas probabilidades vamos a
ver otra forma de calcular las entonces
necesitamos espacio
y calculemos la probabilidad de obtener
no sé digamos un 5
entonces digamos que tenemos por aquí lo
que sale en el dado 1 y por acá lo que
sale en el dado 2 aunque bueno esto
aunque no sea una cuadrícula inmensa
también parece un poco de cuadrícula
verdad bueno también podríamos llamarle
tabla el chiste es que cuáles son las
posibilidades del dado 1 el dado uno
puede sacar un 1 2 3
4 5 y 6 ahora para que la suma de los
dos dados sea 5 si nuestro dado 1 ya
tiró un 1 cuáles son los posibles tiros
del dado 2 que hacen que la suma sea 5
pues no además el 4 no lo sea porque uno
más cuatro y cinco pero uno más
cualquier otra cosa que no sea cuatro ya
va a ser distinto de cinco y bueno
hacemos lo mismo para el dos de hecho
podríamos hacerlo más fácil como 5 menos
23 y si sale 3 en el dado 1 que nos
tiene que salir en el dado 2 para que la
suma sea 5 pues tiene que salir un 2 si
sale 4 tiene que salir un 1 y aquí
empieza la parte interesante si en el
dado uno sale 5 no hay nada que nos
pueda salir en el dado 2 que haga que la
suma sea igual a 5 o sea porque lo más
chico que nos puede salir el dado 2 es 1
entonces esta opción la tenemos que
tachar al igual que esta otra opción así
es que si queremos que la suma de los
dos dados sea 5
las únicas opciones que tenemos son
estas cuatro a ver entonces estamos
nosotros por aquí y digamos que aquí
vamos a poner los resultados del dado 1
y aquí vamos a poner los resultados del
dado 2 ok tenemos aquí la tabla pero ya
pensé que para calcular las
probabilidades igual y puede ser muy
útil hacer un árbol de probabilidad
entonces estamos aquí y en el dado 1
podemos tirar 6 opciones ok podemos
tirar 1 2 3 4 5 6 cada uno de estos
tiros pues tiene una probabilidad de un
sexto muy grave y acabamos de ver por
aquí que si tiramos 5 o tiramos 6
entonces yo no podemos llegar a un
resultado en el que la suma de 5 ahora
una vez que ya sacamos un 1 en el
segundo dado nos puede salir uno dos
tres cuatro cinco o seis cierto y cada
uno de estos resultados sale con
probabilidad un sexto sin embargo ya
vimos todas estas posibilidades
hacen que la suma de estos dos dados no
sea igual a 5 el único rayito de sol que
tenemos por aquí es que en el segundo
dado no salga 4 y eso sucede con
probabilidad un sexto
entonces por aquí podemos agregar otra
columna que se llame probabilidad probar
del evento del
evento donde recuerden que un evento es
simplemente un conjunto de resultados
aquí y aquí estamos usando eventos para
referirnos a cada uno de los resultados
en los que nos sale 1 y 4 nos sale 2 y 3
y así pero bueno el chiste
es que aquí en esta columna vamos a
escribir la probabilidad de que nos
salga esto de aquí a la derecha aunque
la probabilidad que nos salga primero un
1 y después un cuarto es un sexto de que
nos salga un 1 en el dado 1 por un sexto
de que no salga 4 en el segundo dado y
podemos multiplicar estas probabilidades
porque estos dos dados son
independientes ya que hay este dado no
está pensando el dado 1 tiro 1 entonces
yo voy a tirar tal cosa aunque hay
entonces la probabilidad de que salga
esto es igual a un sexto por un sexto
que es igual a un
36 sabe que ahí podemos hacer
exactamente lo mismo para 2 y 3
aquí la probabilidad que no salga 2 es
un sexto después el dado 2 tiene seis
opciones de las cuales sólo una que en
este caso va a ser ésta nos sirve para
que la suma de los dos dados sea igual a
5 y esto ocurre con probabilidad de un
sexto entonces nos queda un sexto por un
sexto
136 sabor y exactamente lo mismo pasa
con estos otros dos resultados aunque
hay su probabilidad es un 36 sabor
ahora puedes notar algo muy curioso aquí
y es que cada uno de estos resultados es
un cuadrito de la cuadrícula que
estábamos viendo hace rato entonces
estos cuatro resultados resultan ser una
diagonal
resultan ser esta
diagonal pero bueno yo creo que sería
bueno regresar a la tabla
a ver ya regresamos a la tablet y ahora
sí vamos a calcular la probabilidad de
obtener un 5 pero usando esta tabla
aunque ya sabemos que la podemos
calcular perfectamente con la cuadrícula
de arriba ya está vimos que estos
cuadritos forman una diagonal en esa
cuadrícula pero queremos calcular la
probabilidad usando esta tabla entonces
aquí tenemos a todos los resultados que
hacen que la suma de los dos dados sea
igual a 5 así es que para calcular la
probabilidad de que la suma de los dados
sea igual a 5 lo único que tenemos que
hacer es sumar la probabilidad de que
ocurra cada uno de estos eventos
entonces tenemos que sumar 1 2 3 4 veces
1 entre 36 y eso es igual a 4 entre 36
y 36 entre 4 es igual a 9 entonces esto
es igual a un noveno aunque la
probabilidad de obtener un 5 es igual a
un noveno bueno ya vimos distintas
formas de obtener esta probabilidad no
siempre que calcule es una probabilidad
tienes que obtenerla de muchas formas
distintas pero sí es bueno saber
distintas formas de calcular las porque
en cada experimento hay una forma que
sirven más que las otras
así es que te veo en el próximo vídeo